there is a lot of lovable and
charismatic characters in FX legends and
Dave you've been playing perhaps the
most lovable of them all he is the
biggest boy he is very lovable I do want
to give him a hug but you brought that I
love him but at the same time he's a
hard guy to love he's probably the one
of the heroes that needs the most work
right now he might be one of the weakest
heroes and apex legends as much sir
pains me to say as mostly because he's
massive alright so give us the basics of
Gibraltar well well the first thing you
need to know if you're gonna play him he
has got the biggest hitbox of the game
paired with caustic pathfinder they've
also got big hit boxes but Gibraltar
suffers more for it so if you're gonna
if you're gonna play him you're gonna
get hit a lot
you expect his passive ability gun
shield to kind of prevent that but it
also has its own problems so when you
aim down sight you get shield pop-up
that covers basically your torso but the
shield only has a little health for me
the biggest issue with the shield is his
right it's so bright it's like an LED
goes off it's bright orange if
somebody's scoping into a hill and you
aim down sights bright orange and there
is an option to toggle it off but but
it's it's pointless you need to be so
very deliberate with Gibraltar the up
the up side of his shield is that he
could make Peaks that some characters
can't if you if you peak to take a
sniper shot on the sniper that you're
aiming at Peaks you at the same time
you've got an advantage because you're
gonna soak up at least one bullet while
you're gonna yours is hopefully going to
hit that that shield does give you a
little more survivability but when you
pair that with his big hitbox and the
fact that you are going to get hit more
it doesn't feel like it's a fair trade
there's a slight delay to the shield
coming out right so like yeah deliberate
deliberate element that you're talking
about you almost have to if you're going
to peak you have to pre aim down sights
right yeah
always be aiming down sights the
Gibraltar which feels so alien in apex
legends because he is much not
physically snow his attributes aren't
slower but because of his kit you end up
playing him slower the gun shield can
soak up a little bit but it only works
when you've got a gun equipped I think
the gun shield
needs some work as does his main ability
I think honestly the the dome shield
that's it's a tricky one it's it's great
to give you some cover it's great to
kind of get out of Dodge one of my
methods of using it is to chuck it down
and keep running through it so that they
you know expect you to be in the dome
shield it can be really good for helping
get someone up or make sure you're not
gonna get shot while looting it does
have some really nice instances where it
can be really valuable but the way I see
a lot of people use it is that it's like
a panic button right as soon as they
take damage as soon as they they crack
their shields they just spam it onto the
ground and hide and for me when I'm when
I'm not playing in travolta and I've
attacked someone and I could I see them
dome shield straightaway that says to me
they're weak they're vulnerable they're
scared now is the time to push this this
goes back into its gibraltars big hit
box if you're forcing a team to push
into your shield or it's close quarters
you're losing that fight because in
those close quarters if enemy Wraith is
coming in and bouncing around as a very
small hitbox can slide it they're gonna
get the drop on you and you can't even
use your gun shield because you have to
aim down sights turn very slow so it's
it's definitely double as short and the
messaging that I think is in the meta
right now is that some people are
looking at dome shields as a sign saying
we're weak the best application is
actually pairing it with his ultimate
now I've talked a lot about gibraltars
kit but ultimate is s-rank he has one of
the greatest Ultimates in the game it's
super high damage it's really consistent
it's super easy to use and it has lots
and lots of uses so one even break down
way actually does so the defensive
bombardment you throw your kind of smoke
canister and it calls in a quite a
concentrated bombardment loads of
explosions anything that you want to
just be flattened and disappear you
throw your defensive bomb bomb now and
one of the greatest applications is
using it with your dome shield if you
time it just right you can throw your
defensive bombardment get into it and
bearing in mind it will cause damage to
Gibraltar not steam but to Gibraltar
so you can throw your bombardment get
under it pop your shield down just after
that and that gives you all the time in
the world to get people up so to Phoenix
kits I'll get shields to get health
because obviously they're gonna have a
really hard time pushing you it not not
only into your shield but through that
defensive bombardment and despite having
called the defensive bombardment I
actually mostly use it offensively in
tight end circles it does so much damage
if you're catching a team looting or
stuck in a choke from my experience of
using it and also it being used against
me it's very effective and kind of
basically manipulate their movements
using the bombardment of it they're dead
yeah exactly
so think of it as like a almost like a
manipulated mary earlier than ion
movement manipulation ability so when I
when I play Gibraltar I try to grab an
LMG and maybe a DMR like a g7 Scout
Spitfire is a great shout on him because
you can take those mid-range that's
where really excels those mid-range
fights because if you see a Gibraltar
come out or only any character come out
open up with a Spitfire that's a lot of
damage are putting downrange
but you can often counter that with your
own weapons but that gun shield at that
mid range with that volume of bullets
can actually get you enough damage
downrange
to force them to retreat and with DMR's
maybe with a longbow with like a full
time scope or a g7 Scout it's a tricky
one right because you expect them to
with those sniper rifles take advantage
of a surprise and you're probably not
going to get that because your bright
eyes shield but if you're swapping shots
with someone else who's has a similar
loadout it might make you at least just
just that one shot that allow you to
live that little longer might turn the
complete fight in you're tied well if
you agree with Dave and if you want to
talk to us about Jibril or any of the
other apex legends find us on Twitter
I'm at more hatred I'm at a regular Dave
signaling to their strengths
[Music]